China appears to be constructing the
ultimate tool of social control
a comprehensive credit score system that
will make your head spin
that's what the American civil liberties
Union ACLU wrote on October 5th 2015.
this newly emerging soon-to-be
all-encompassing surveillance Network it
said would give everyone in China a
score between 350 and 950.
but unlike say American credit scores
these would punish everything from
jaywalking to government criticism
even more disturbingly you could be
responsible for the actions of your
friends and family
the rest of the article mainly focused
on the United States the ACLU after all
is an American non-profit it lobbies for
things like free speech privacy and
Criminal Justice Reform
this was not new reporting the author
was open about his sources other
articles he had read online
neither did he claim to have any
expertise on China
in fact just three days later he updated
the article softening the tone and
emphasizing that he only meant to
caution against potential abuses in
America
but it didn't matter
What mattered was that a high-profile
well-respected institution had stamped
its seal of approval and other
organizations took notice
two days after the original ACLU article
went live and a day before it issued the
update Computer World republished it
calling the Chinese system orwellian
Popular Science wrote that although
quote the system isn't explicitly
dystopian yet it has all the pieces to
be dystopian at a moment's notice
and reason claimed these scores would
soon Define Chinese citizens lives
in less than a week the social credit
system had not only entered the English
media landscape but also seemingly a
massed body of evidence
multiple sources endorsing the same
alarming conclusion
never mind that they all reference the
same ACLU report written by a non-expert
largely about the United States itself
based on earlier speculation
news travels fast and headlines even
faster
there was no need for some Grand
conspiracy to smear China or bad faith
on the part of any individual author
the simple Market pressures of 21st
century journalism were enough to make a
story appear out of thin air
America is often quite Justified
suspicion of the Chinese government and
technology in general or just icing on
the cake
since then the social credit system has
truly taken on a life of its own with
coverage by the financial times
Economist fortune and countless others
this now eight-year-old game of
telephone culminated in an appearance at
the White House with vice president Mike
Pence describing it as an orwellian
system premised on controlling virtually
every facet of human life
and yet ask a friend colleague or
classmate who spent time in China about
their experience and you'll likely be
met with confusion
this is not a case of censorship
the Chinese government does engage in
extensive censorship but for the social
credit system to work as described the
public must be at a minimum aware of its
existence
neither is this the result of propaganda
the government does engage in propaganda
but in this case the response is not
anger frustration or disagreement just
confusion
because for all of its well-documented
genuine atrocities the orwellian credit
score system imagined by many in the
media simply doesn't exist
the truth however is far more revealing
sponsored by skillshare get a one month
free trial and start learning everything
from programming to graphic design
in June 2014 the state Council of China
published this planning outline for the
establishment of a social credit system
now the first thing you should know
about this document is that it's
incredibly boring and almost artfully
vague
full of dense phrases like promote the
Improvement of legal person governance
you almost have to admire how little it
manages to say in 16 000 Chinese
characters
the second thing to note is the broader
context in which it was released
one month earlier in May of 2014 the
same government announced what it
described as a war on terror against
violent extremism in xinjiang
this would later evolve into a
full-blown attack on uyghurs and other
ethnic minorities including Mass
incarcerations surveillance and violence
that continues in modified form to this
day
in other words this was a time when much
of the world was becoming understandably
increasingly skeptical of the Chinese
government and here was this new
suspiciously ambiguous notion of social
credit
the motive for some kind of inescapable
system of surveillance and control
seemed undeniable
in fact what made the myth so potent was
that it did contain an element of Truth
in the years since China has constructed
a similarly oppressive albeit less
high-tech police state in xinjiang
involving DNA collection phone searches
and security checkpoints
besides what else could the term social
credit refer to
and if it truly had nothing to hide why
was the plan written in such cryptic
language
but would few casual observers
understood is that cryptic inscrutable
leninist steeped jargon is kind of the
Chinese Communist party's whole thing
and there's a very specific reason
the benefits of autocracy for an
autocrat are so obvious complete
unchecked Authority that it's easy to
forget the trade-off
with complete Authority comes complete
responsibility there's no one to blame
consider how often Democrats and
Republicans use each other as scapegoats
dictators don't have that luxury
so to insulate themselves from criticism
they often delegate a lot more power
than you might expect
now make no mistake Beijing always gets
the final word but think of it as an
architect
it produces the national blueprint first
in the form of a policy document and
later a policy outline but whose actual
implementation it outsources to lower
levels of government its engineers
when the actual Building looks nothing
like the concept art the central
government can keep its hands clean by
pointing to its beautifully vague
boringly unobjectionable sketches
at the same time it also of course has
things it wants to accomplish things
that need to be communicated to the
engineers
thus while these policy documents as we
saw are indeed horribly tedious they're
not entirely devoid of content you just
have to understand party speak
[Music]
so what did it mean by social credit
according to Jeremy Dom senior fellow at
Yale law schools Paul Thai China Center
and someone fluent in party speak it was
never a single policy it wasn't even a
very well outlined goal
instead it was always quote shorthand
for a broad range of efforts
the first of which was Financial
in short the millions born before the
one child policy became law in 1980 were
in their Prime working age years during
the Chinese boom of the 80s 90s and
early 2000s
that large massive workers kept labor
costs down attracting foreign companies
who in turn invested that profit back
into the country
but as all those workers began to retire
Chinese labor became a lot more
expensive leading to lower profits and
therefore less investment
that investment however could be
replaced with consumption
in summary if China was to keep growing
it needed to start spending
yet at the time just one-fifth of the
population had a credit report
without banks or credit cards they
couldn't take out loans and without
loans they couldn't spend as much money
meanwhile much of this large unbanked
population used Chinese apps like WeChat
and alipay on a daily basis
so the thinking was what if all that
data could be used to create alternative
credit scores
eight private companies were selected to
do just that as part of a pilot project
the most famous was Sesame credit an
optional service that gave users a
three-digit score
the second and larger focus of social
credit was centered around trust
ironically while Outsiders view China as
a tightly controlled closely monitored
police state many in China saw their
country as the wild west
untamed unregulated and lacking in
consequences
in 2008 for instance a company was
caught using toxic chemicals in its milk
and baby formula making thousands of
children sick
scandals like these left deep Nationwide
scars
some parents are understandably still
suspicious of Chinese milk today
at the same time corruption once
tolerated as a necessary ingredient to
Rapid economic growth was beginning to
reach a boiling point
Not only was the party losing control of
its own members but the public was
starting to take notice
stories of County bureaucrats driving
Lamborghinis despite their measly
official salaries were attracting a bit
too much attention
and in the eyes of the party all these
things were connected the milk the
corruption it all represented a crisis
of moral failure
one consequence of which was a general
lack of trust throughout Chinese Society
the solution was to build what it called
in its typically ambiguous way a
reputation Society
remember this was the architect telling
the engineer here's a vaguely defined
problem now go try and solve it
the results were as random and chaotic
as you'd expect
what as a local bureaucrat are you
supposed to do with these instructions
no one knows and that's the point
a few dozen cities across China rushed
to implement their own social credit
reputation systems each with their own
set of rules and Rewards
one city announced it would subtract
three points for every five cigarettes
smoked and add five for every fifteen
thousand steps walked
no explanation was offered for how these
numbers were determined much less how
this could possibly be enforced but it
didn't matter the public backlash was so
strong that the proposal was abandoned
bizarrely another city said it would
penalize drunk driving and reward
volunteer work but then decided to make
this system optional
City gave every citizen a grade from a
to d until someone compared it to the
Japanese Occupation of China and it
quietly disappeared
it was all very weird and impractical
needless to say the central government
was thoroughly unimpressed
evidently the construction didn't match
the blueprint
alternatively perhaps Beijing
miscalculated The public's reaction and
saw its opportunity to swoop in and
protect the country from those terrible
no-good engineers
The People's Bank of China refused to
renew the licenses of all eight
companies participating in the financial
pilot project
Beijing also called out several local
governments for being overzealous
instructing them to only punish what was
already illegal
the third and final component of social
credit are blacklists
previously each government Ministry
maintains separate records meaning
someone could violate the rules of say
the tax authorities without the food
inspector knowing
now they're supposed to share that data
not only internally but also with the
public so for example you could search
the name of a company and decide if it's
reputable
generally trustworthy entities are
placed on so-called red lists and repeat
offenders on blacklists
most of these are companies though their
owners and managers can be implicated
too
as a ballpark somewhere between one and
two percent of companies and 0.15 to 0.3
percent of people are blacklisted each
year
in the most extreme case offenders are
banned from taking flights or trains or
sending their children to private
schools
but these restrictions only apply to one
type of offense those who refuse to pay
damages found by a judge despite having
their requisite funds
once they've fulfilled their court
orders they're removed from The
Blacklist
by 2018 over 12 million of these
judgment defaulters had been affected
some cities even broadcast their names
in movie theaters
okay let's review
one part of social credit was Financial
one about cities incentivizing good
behavior and the third an attempt to
share government data
the first involved eight companies the
second dozens of different cities and
the third several independent Ministries
one was Private the other two public
some were optional others not
together they have very little in common
besides the label social credit
if you're not at least slightly confused
by now you should probably be concerned
remember this was not designed for
Global comprehension
actually it wasn't really designed for
local comprehension
it was designed to leave the door open
for experimentation and to retain some
plausible deniability for the central
government
so it should be no surprise that
virtually every detail was lost on the
media
instead of three separate projects many
journalists lumped them all together as
one
the inputs of privately owned Sesame
credit your shopping behavior for
instance were paired with a
state-sponsored punishments of the
entirely separate blacklists travel
restrictions for example
thus the story became if you buy the
wrong things the CCP will ban you from
travel
social credit was an easy device through
which to conceive of and critique
Chinese authoritarianism
the irony being that the reason this
1984 style surveillance was so
believable in the first place is also
the reason the party doesn't need it
Chinese surveillance isn't some new
development
the battle for anonymity was lost well
before the birth of social credit
all accounts on all Chinese websites
require real name registration so does
every SIM card and internet cafe
if and when laws including social credit
are weaponized it's because of the
underlying system the nearly unchecked
discretion afforded to individual police
officers and bureaucrats
now it would be clean and simple to end
the video here by concluding that
journalists are just lazy and ran with a
false narrative
but that too would be lazy
this is not just a case of journalists
seeing what they wanted to see because
China also feeds into these pre-existing
anxieties
to see how humor me with one final
tangent
in democracies politics seem to get in
the way of Simple Solutions to Health
Care education and infrastructure
when Congress can't seem to get anything
done it's easy to start thinking of
Party politics as a bug not a feature
if only I were General Secretary for a
day everything would be so much better
if democracy is messy inefficient and
complicated autocracy must be clean
efficient and simple
but not necessarily
if you're a student think about the last
time you tried to herd the sheep that
were the members of your group project
if you work in an office recall how
difficult it is to get sales and finance
to collaborate
now multiply that complexity by 100
million people the size of the Communist
Party
though they may March under the same
Banner people are people 100 million
members means 100 million feuds
allegiances and career ambitions
by delegating power in order to share
responsibility China opens the door to a
certain version of messy politics
both the local governments and private
companies responsible for implementing
beijing's vision of social credit had
their own incentives one of which was to
overstate their capabilities
if you think Silicon Valley is the
capital of empty buzzwords try talking
to Executives at Alibaba or party
officials from up-and-coming cities like
Suzhou
desperate to impress their bosses in
Beijing they throw around terms like big
data blockchain and smart cities like
it's no one's business
take Sesame credit for instance
the curry favor with the authorities the
company painted a beautiful picture full
of super Advanced algorithms to entice
users it advertised powerful benefits
like travel visas to Europe
the English language media already
believing Sesame credit to be the
official manifestation of social credit
effectively bought into this marketing
which it then resold to a global
Audience by emphasizing how this super
advanced technology could be weaponized
in reality Sesame credit was a frankly
amateur version of the Target Red Card
it calculated how often not what you
purchased whether you'd completed your
profile not what it said and how many
accounts you'd added on the app as
friends not who they were
in exchange for sharing this basic data
with a company you could do things like
rent a bike without leaving a deposit
a high score couldn't Grant you a visa
to Europe only Europe can do that
all it could do is help prove your
finances replacing one of several
documents required to apply
likewise local governments love nebulous
terms like social credit because unlike
say GDP growth it's very hard to measure
this lack of oversight makes it all too
easy to exaggerate claims about
algorithms which often meant simple
addition and subtraction and big data
which was often recorded on spreadsheets
or in one city I kid you not clipboards
this for instance is the average number
of data points per citizen in each of
these five pilot cities
the social credit dystopia imagined by
many on the other hand would require
close coordination between hundreds of
different Ministries all of which are
competing for promotions budget
allocations and Regulatory Authority
this is not at all to say China is
incapable of doing big and scary things
the point is that we should approach its
claims about big data and machine
learning with the same degree of
skepticism as we would any Silicon
Valley startup
currently one side is primed to see
China as 10 feet tall and the other is
incentivized to exaggerate its height
what could go wrong
conversely what you can't go wrong with
are these classes on productivity and
learning new things with spaced
repetition that can help you advance or
kick-start a new career
we all have dreams goals and creative
projects in mind but if you're like me
you need a little push to get things
going
maybe you've always wanted to learn
graphic design but don't know where to
start this class walks you through
everything you need to know about
Photoshop right from the very basics
skillshare is an online learning
community with not only thousands of
courses on everything from graphic
design to programming but also a
superior learning environment
by sharing your work with others getting
feedback and asking questions you can
engage with each lesson and feel
rewarded
because you get access to every lesson
with a single subscription You're
motivated to make the most of your
membership
first 1000 people to join by clicking
the link on screen now get a one month
free trial that's one full month you can
take unlimited classes with no
restrictions thanks again to skillshare
for sponsoring this video